so i'm excited to talk today about
our recent work on using transformers
for reinforcement learning
and this is joint work with a bunch of
really
exciting collaborators most of them at
uc berkeley
and some of them at facebook and google
uh i should mention this book was led by
very two talented undergrads lichen and
kevin bloom
and
i'm excited to present the results we
had
so let's
try to motivate why we even care about
this problem
so
uh we have seen in the last three or
four years that transformers
since the introduction in 2017 have
taken over lots and lots of different
fields of artificial
intelligence so we saw them having a big
impact for language processing
we saw them being used for vision in the
vision transformer very recently
they were in nature trying to solve
protein folding
and very soon they might just took place
as computer scientists by having
automatically generate code
uh so with all of these advances it
seems like we are getting closer to
having a unified model for decision
making
uh or for artificial intelligence but
artificial intelligence
is much more about not just having
perception but also using the perception
knowledge to make decisions
and this is what this talk is going to
be about
but before i go into actually thinking
about how we will use these models for
decision making here is a motivation for
why i think it is important to ask this
question
so
unlike
models for rl
when we look at transformers uh for
perception modalities like i showed in
the previous slide
we find that these models are very
scalable and have very stable
training dynamics
so you can keep as long as you have
enough computation and you have more and
more data that can be sourced
you can train bigger and bigger models
and you'll see very smooth reductions in
the loss
um
and the overall training dynamics are
very
are very stable and this makes it very
easy for practitioners and researchers
to build these models
um and
learn richer and richer distributions
so like i said
uh all of these advances have so far
occurred in perception uh what would be
interested in this talk is to think
about how we can go from perception
uh looking at images looking at text and
all these kinds of sensory signals to
then going into the field of actually
taking actions
and making
our agents do interesting things in the
world
uh
and here throughout the talk we should
be thinking about why this perspective
is going to enable us to do
scalable learning like i show in the
previous slide as well as bring
stability into the whole procedure
so sequential decision making is a very
broad area
and what
i'm specifically going to be focusing on
today is one route to sequential
decision making that's reinforcement
learning
so uh just as a brief background uh
what is reinforcement learning so we are
given an agent
uh who's in a current state and the
agent is going to interact with the
environment by taking actions
and by taking these actions the
environment is going to return to it a
reward
for how good that action was
as well as next state into which the
agent will transition and this whole
feedback loop will continue
the goal here for an intelligent agent
is to then
using trial and error so try out
different actions see what rewards will
lead to
learn a policy which maps your states to
actions such that the policy maximizes
the agent's cumulative rewards over time
horizon
so you take a sequence of actions and
then based on the reward you accumulate
for that sequence of action actions will
judge how good your policy is
this talk um is also going to be
specifically focused on a form of
reinforcement learning that goes by the
name of offline reinforcement learning
so the idea here is that
what changes from the previous picture
where i was talking about online
learning online reinforcement learning
is that here
now instead of doing actively
interacting with the environment
you have a collection of log data of
interactions so think about some robot
that's going out in the fields and it it
collects a bunch of sensory data and
you've all locked it and using that log
data you now want to train another agent
it could be another robot
to then learn something interesting
about that environment just by looking
at log data
okay so there's no trial and error
component
which is currently one of the
extensions of this framework which would
be very exciting so i'll talk about this
towards the end of the talk why it's
exciting to think about how we extend
how we can extend this framework to
include an expiration component and have
trial and error
okay so uh
not now to go more concretely into what
the motivating challenge of the stock
was now that we have introduced rl
uh so let's look at some statistics
so large language models i have billions
of parameters
and they have
right today they have roughly about 100
layers in transformer
uh they're very stable to train using
supervised learning uh style losses
which are the building blocks of auto
regressive generation for instance or
for mass language modeling as in but
um
and this is like an field that's growing
every day and this is a course on it at
stanford that we're all taking just
because it has had such a monumental
impact on ai
rl policies on the other hand uh and i'm
talking about deep rl uh
the maximum they would extend to is
maybe millions of parameters or 20
layers
um
and
what's really unnerving is that they're
very unstable to train so the current
algorithms for reinforcement learning
they build on
a mostly dynamic programming which
involves solving an inner loop
optimization problem that's very
unstable and it's very common to see
practitioners in rl looking at reward
curves that look like this
so what i really want is you to see here
is the variance in the returns that
we tend to get in rl
it's really huge even after doing
multiple rounds of experimentation
and that's often that is really at the
core got to done with the fact that
um our algorithms
learning checks need
uh better improvements so that the
performance can be stably achieved by
agents
in complex environments
so
what this work is uh hoping to do is
it's going to introduce transformers
and i'll first show in one slide what
exactly that model looks like and we're
going to go into
uh deeper details of each of the
components
yeah can i ask a question real quick
uh yes
and thank you
what i'm curious to know is what is the
what is the cause for why rl typically
has several orders of magnitude fewer
parameters
uh that's a great question so
typically when you think about
reinforcement learning algorithms
uh
in deep rl in particular so the most
common algorithms for example have
different networks playing different
roles in
uh the
in the task so you'll have a network for
instance playing the role of an actor
uh since trying to figure out a policy
and then there'll be a different network
that's playing the role of a critic
and these networks are trained on data
that's adaptively gathered so unlike
perception where you will have
a huge data set
of interactions on which you can train
your
models
in this case the architectures and even
the environments to some extent
are
very simplistic because of the fact that
we are trying to train very small
components the functions that you're
training and then bringing them all
together
and
these functions
uh are often trained in not super
complex environments
so it's a mix of different issues i
wouldn't say it's purely just what it
would do with the fact that
the learning objective is our fault but
it's a combination of the environments
we use the combination of the targets
that each of the neural networks are
predicting
which leads to
networks which are much bigger than
what we currently see tending to overfit
and that's why it's very common to see
neural networks with
much fewer layers being used in rl as
opposed to perception
thank you
you want to ask a question
yep
yeah i was going to um is there a reason
why you chose offline rl versus online
rl
uh that's that's another great question
so the question is why offline are as
opposed to online rl
um and the the plain reason is because
this is the first work trying to look at
reinforcement learning uh so offline rl
avoids this problem of exploration
you are given a log data set of
interactions you're not allowed to
further interact with the environment
so just from this data set you're trying
to unearth a policy of what the optimal
agent would look like
so it would right like if you do online
rl wouldn't that like just give you this
opportunity of exploration
basically
it would it would what it would also do
which is technically challenging here
is that
the exploration would be harder to
encode so offline r is the first step
there is no reason why
we should not study why online url
cannot be done it's just that it
provides a more contained setup where
ideas from transformers will directly
extend
okay uh sounds good so let's look at the
model and it's really simple on purpose
so what we're going to do is we're going
to look at our offline data
which is essentially in the form of
trajectories
so
offline data would look like a sequence
of states actions
returns
over multiple time steps
it's a sequence
so it's natural to think of us as
directly feeding it as input to a
transformer
in this case we use a causal causal
transformer as it's common in gpt
uh so we go from left to right and
because this data set comes with the
notion of time step causality here is
much more well intended than the general
meaning that's used for perception this
is really causality
how it should be in in perspective of
time
what we predict out of this transformer
are the actions conditioned on
everything that comes before that token
in the sequence
so if you want to predict the action at
this t minus one step we'll use
everything that came
at time step t minus 2
as well as the returns and states at
time step t minus 1.
so
we will go into the details of how
exactly each of these are encoded
uh but essentially this is uh in in a
one-liner it's taking the trajectory
data from the offline data treating it
as a sequence of tokens passing it
through a causal transformer and getting
a sequence of actions as the output
okay so
how exactly do we do the forward pass
through the network
uh so
one important aspect of this work which
is
we
use states actions and this quantity
called returns to go
so these are not direct rewards
uh these are returns to go and i'll and
let's see what they really
are mean
so
this is our trajectory that goes in good
to decision
and the returns to go
are the sum of rewards starting from the
current time step into
until the end of the episode
so really what we want the transformer
is to get better at using a target
return this is how you should think of
returns to go
as the input in deciding what action to
take
this perspective is going to have
multiple advantages it will allow us to
actually do much more than offline rl
and generalizing to different tasks
by just changing the returns to go
uh and here it's very important so at
time step one we will just have the
overall sum of rewards for the entire
trajectory
at time step two we subtract the reward
we get by taking the first action and
then have the sum of rewards for the
remainder of the trajectory
okay so uh that's how we call it returns
to go uh like how many more rewards
in in accumulation you need to acquire
uh to fulfill your
reward your return goal that you set
from the beginning
what is the output
the output is the sequence of predicted
actions
so
as i showed in the previous slide
we use the causal transformer so we'll
predict
in sequence
the desired actions
the attention
which is uh
[Music]
going to be computed inside the
transformer will take in an important
hyper parameter k which is the context
length
uh we see that in perception as well
here and for the rest of the talk i'm
going to use the notation k to denote
how many tokens in the past
would we be attending over to predict uh
the action at the current time step
okay so again uh
digging a little bit deeper into code
um there are some subtle differences
with how
[Music]
a decision transformer
operates as opposed to a normal
transformer
the first is that here the time step
notion is going to be
have a much bigger semantics that
extends across three tokens
so
in perception you just think about the
time step
per
word for instance like in nlp or per
patch for vision and in this case we
will have a time step
encapsulating three tokens one for the
states one for the actions and one for
the rewards
and then we'll embed each of these
uh
tokens and then add the position
embedding as it's common in the
transformer
and we feed those inputs to
the transformer
at the output we only care about one of
these three tokens in in this default
setup we i will show experiments where
even the other tokens might be of
interest as target predictions but for
now let's keep it simple we want to
learn a policy a policy which is trying
to predict actions
so when we try to decode we'll only be
looking at the actions
uh in from the hidden representation in
the pre-final layer
okay so this is the forward pass now
what do we do with this network we train
it
how do we train it
sorry just a quick question on semantics
there uh if you go back one slide
the the plus in this case the syntax
means that you are actually adding the
values element-wise and not
concatenating them is that right
that is correct okay
okay so what's the last function um
follow up on that i thought it was
concur why are we just adding it
sorry can you go back
yeah i think it's it's a design choice
you can continue it you can add it
it leads to different functions being
encoded in our case it's this edition
okay
why did you did you try the other one
and it just didn't work or
why is that because i think intuitively
concatenating would like make more sense
uh so
i think both of them have different uh
use cases for the functional encoding
like one is really
mixing in the embeddings for the state
and basically shifting it so when you uh
when you add something you if you think
of the embedding of the states as
a vector and you add something you are
actually shifting it
whereas in the concatenation case you
are actually increasing the
dimensionality of this space
yeah
so those are different choices which are
doing very different things
uh we found this one to be worked better
i'm not sure i remember if the results
were very significantly different if you
would concatenate them but this is the
one which uh we operate with
but wouldn't there be because like if
you're shifting it right like if you
have an embedding for a state and let's
say like you perform certain actions and
you like end up at the same state again
you would want these embeddings to be
the same however now you're at a
different time step so like you shifted
it so wouldn't that be like harder to
learn
so there's this is there's a bigger an
interesting question in that what you
said is basically are we losing the
markov property
uh because as you said that
if we come back to the same state at a
different time step uh shouldn't we be
uh
have doing similar operations and the
answer here is yes we are actually being
non-markov
and this might seem very non-intuitive
at first that why are
uh why is
non-markovness important here
uh and
um i want to refer to another paper
which came very much in conjunction with
this attractive transformer that
actually shows in more detail
and it's basically say that if you were
trying to predict the transition
dynamics
then you could have actually had a
markovian system built in here which
which would do just as good
however for the perspective of
uh trying to actually predict actions um
it does help to look at the previous
time steps even more so when you have
missing observations so for instance if
you have uh the observations being a
substitute of the true state
so looking at the previous states and
actions helps you
better fill in the missing pieces in
some sense so this is commonly known as
partial observability where you by
looking at the previous tokens you can
do a better job at
predicting the actions you should take
at the current uh time step
so now non-markovness is on purpose
uh and it's not intuitive
uh but i think it's one of the things
which separates this framework from
existing ones
so it will basically help you because
like rl usually works on like infinite
like it works better on like infinite
horizon problems right so technically
the way you formulate it it would work
better on finite horizon problems i'm
assuming because you want to take
different actions based on like a
history based on like given the fact
that now you took a different timestamp
yeah yeah so if you wanted to work on
infinite verizon maybe something like
this counting would work uh just as well
to get that effect in this case we
were
using a discount factor of one or
basically like notice standing at all
uh but you're right if i think we really
want to extend it to internet horizon we
would need to change the discount factor
okay thanks
okay so
good question
oh
i think it was just answered in chat but
i'll ask it anyways um i think i might
have missed this or maybe you're about
to talk about it the offline data that
was collected what policy was used to
collect it
uh
so this is a very important question and
it will
be something i mentioned the experiments
so we were using the benchmarks that
exist for signal where essentially uh
the way these benchmarks are constructed
is
you train an agent using online rl and
then you look at its replay buffer at
some time step
so while it's training so while it's
like a medium sort of expert you collect
its trans uh the transitions it's
experienced so far and make that as the
offline data it's it's something which
is
like our framework is very agnostic to
what offline data that you use so so i'm
not discussing
the car
but something that uh in our experiments
is based on traditional benchmarks
got it so the reason i ask isn't i'm
sure that your framework can accommodate
any offline data but it seems to me like
the results that you're about to present
are going to be heavily contingent
on what that that data collection policy
is
indeed indeed and also uh uh so so we
will i think i have a slide where we
show an experiment where the amount of
data can make a difference
in how we compare with baselines and
essentially
uh we will see how distant transformer
especially shines when
there is
small amounts of offline data
okay cool thank you
okay great questions uh so let's let's
go ahead so we have to find our model
uh which is going to look at
these trajectories
um
and now let's see how we train it
uh so very simple uh we will we are
trying to predict actions uh we'll try
to match them to the ones we have in our
data set if they're continuous using the
mean squared error if they're discrete
and we can use the cross entropy
um
so but there is something very deep in
here
for
our research which is that
these objectives are very stable to
train and easy to regularize because
they've been developed for supervised
learning
in contrast what arl is more used to is
dynamic programming style objectives
which are based on the bellman equation
and those end up being much harder to
optimize and scale and that's why you
see a lot of the variants in the results
as well
okay so this is how we train the model
now how do we use the model and that's
the point about
trying to do roll out for the model
uh so here again uh this is going to be
similar to doing an auto regressive
generation
um there was an important token here
which was the returns to go
and
what we need to set during evaluation
presumably we want
uh expert level performance
uh because that will have the highest uh
returns so we set the initial returns to
go
uh not based on our trajectory because
now we don't have a trajectory you're
going to generate a transit tree so this
is at inference time so we'll set it to
the export return for instance
so in code what this whole procedure
would look like is basically
you said this returns to go token to as
some target return
and you set your initial state to
one of uh run from the environment
distribution of initial states
uh and then you just roll out your trans
decision transformer
so you get a new action
uh this action will also give you a
state and reward from the environment
you append them to your sequence
and
you get a new returns to go
and you take just the context and keep
because that's what's used by the
transformer to making predictions and
then feed it back to the distance
transformer
so it's it's regular auto regressive
generation
but the only key point to notice is how
you initialize the
uh the transformer for rl
uh sorry to have one question here
so how much does the choice of the
export
mattered is it does it have to be like
the mean expert reward or can it be like
the maximum reward possible in
department
like does the choice of the number
really matter
uh
that's a very good question so we
generally uh would set it to be
slightly higher than
the max return in the data set
so i think the factor we used was 1.1
times
but i think we have done
a lot of experimentation
um
in the range and
it's fairly robust to what choice you
use
uh so for example for hopper expert
returns about 3 600 and we have found
very stable performance from
all the way from like
35 30 400 to even going to very high
numbers like 5000 it it works
um
yeah
uh so uh however i would want to point
out that this is something which is not
typically needed
in regular rl
uh like knowing the export return here
we are actually going beyond regular rl
and that we can choose a return we want
so we also actually need this
information about what the export return
is
at desktop
there's another value
yes
so
yeah it's just that you're it cannot be
on the regular aisle but i i'm just
about to also like
restrict this framework to only offline
io because
if you wanna
run this kind of framework in online
area you'll have to
determine the returns to go aprily
so this kind of remote i think it's kind
of restricted to only offline aisle do
you think so
uh yes and i i think uh
asking this question as well earlier
that
yes i think for now this is the first
book so we were focusing on offline rl
where this information can be gathered
from the offline data set
it is
possible to think about strategies on
how you can even get this online uh what
you'll need is a curriculum so early on
during training as you're gathering data
you will set
when when you're doing rollouts you will
set your export return to whatever you
see in the data set
and then
increment it as in when you start seeing
that the transformer can actually exceed
that performance
so you can think of specifying a
curriculum from slow to high for what
that expert return could be for with
which you roll out there are
trans the
decision
transformer i say cool thank you
so yeah this was about the model so we
discussed um how this model
uh
is
what the input to these models are what
the outputs are what the loss function
is used for training this model and how
do we use this model at test time
uh there is a connection to
uh this framework as being one way to
instantiate what is often known as rl as
probabilistic inference
so we can formulate rl as a graphical
model problem
where you have
the states and actions being used to
determine what the next state is
and to encode a notion of optimality
typically you would also have these
additional auxiliary variables one o2
and so on and forth which are implicitly
saying that
encoding some notion of reward and
conditioned on this optimality being
true
uh rl is the task of learning a policy
uh which is the mapping from
states to actions
such that
we get optimal behavior
and
if you really squint your eyes you can
see that these optimality variables and
decision transformers
are actually being encoded by the
returns to go
so if when we give
a value that's high enough at test time
during rollouts like the expert return
we are essentially saying that
conditioned on this being
the
mathematical uh form quantification of
optimality
uh roll out your discipline transformer
to hopefully satisfy
uh this can this this condition
uh so um
yeah so this was all i want to talk
about the model can you explain that
please
what do you mean by optimality variables
in the decision transformer and how do
you mean like return to go
right so optimality variables um
we can think in the most simplest
context as
uh let's just say they were binary so
one is if you
solve the goal and zero is if you did
not solve the goal
and what basically in that case
you could also think of
your decision transformer
as
a test time and we encode the returns to
go
uh we could set it to one which would
basically mean
that
conditioned on optimality so optimality
here means
uh solving the goal as one
generate me the sequence of actions such
that this would be true
of course our learning is not perfect so
it's not
guaranteed we'll get that
but we have trained the transformer in a
way
to interpret the returns to go as some
notion of optimality
so is it is it
if i'm interpreting this correctly it's
roughly like saying
show me what an optimal sequence of
transitions look like
because you've learned the model has
learned sort of both successful and
unsuccessful transitions
exactly exactly okay
and as we have seen some experiments we
can uh for for the for the binary case
it's either optimal or non-optimal but
really this can be a continuous variable
which it is in our experiment so we can
also see what happens in between
experimentally
okay so let's jump into the experiments
um
so there are a bunch of experiments and
i've
picked out a few which i think are
interesting
and give the key
um
results in the paper but feel free to
reference the paper for an even more
detailed analysis on some of the
components of our model
so
um
this uh so first we can look at how well
does it do an offline rl so there are
benchmarks for
uh
the atari suite of environments and the
open air gym and we have another
environment key to door which is
especially hard because it contains
sparse rewards and requires you to do
credit assignment that i'll talk about
later
but across the board we see that
decision transformer is competitive with
uh the state-of-the-art model free
offline rl methods in this case this was
a version of q learning uh designed for
offline rl
and
it can do
excellent when especially when there is
long-term credit assignment where
traditional methods based on
td learning would fail
uh yeah so the takeaway here should not
be that uh we should we are at the stage
where we can just substitute
uh the existing algorithms for the
decision transformer but this is a very
strong evidence in favor that this
paradigm which is building on
transformers will permit us to better
iterate and improve the models to
hopefully surpass
the existing algorithms uniformly and
there's some early evidence of that in
hard environments which do require
credit assign long-term credit
assignment
okay can i ask a question here about uh
the baseline specifically td learning
i'm curious to know because i know that
a lot of td learning agents are feed
forward networks are these baselines do
they have recurrence
yeah yeah so i think the conservative q
learning baselines here
we did have recurrence but um
i'm not very sure so i can check back on
this offline and get back on this
okay
thank you
also another quick question so uh just
how exactly do you evaluate the decision
transformer here in the experiment so
because you need to supply the returns
to go so then use the optimal
like policy to get what's optimal
rewards and speed yes so here we
basically look at the offline data set
that is used for training and we said um
whatever was the maximum return in the
offline data we set the
uh desired target return to go as
uh slightly higher than that so one
point one involved coefficient we used
i see so uh and the performance sorry
i'm not really well versus or else but
how is the performance defined here just
like is it how much reward you get
actually from the yes yes so
you can specify a target return to go
but there's no guarantee that
the actual actions
that you take will achieve that return
uh so yeah
so you actually you measure the true
environment you're doing basically yeah
i see it but then like just curious like
so what's uh so are these performance
the percentage you get like uh
for
like how much i guess reward do you
recover from
actually involved yeah so these are not
percentages these are some we have
normalizing the return so that
everything was between zero hundred um
yeah yeah i see then uh just wonder if
you have a like a rough idea about how
much
like reward actually is recovered by
decision transformers like does it say
like if you specify i want to get like
50 rewards does he get 49 or is this
even better sometimes or
uh that's an excellent question and my
next slide
i see thanks
uh so here uh we're gonna answer
precisely this question that was asked
is like if you feed in the target return
it could be exploded it could also not
be expert how well does the mall
actually do in attaining it
so
the x-axis is what we specify as the
target return we want
and the y-axis is basically
how much how well do we actually get
uh for reference we have this green line
which is the article so which means
whatever you desire the crystalline
transformer gives it to you so this
would have been the ideal case so it's a
diagonal
um
we also have because this is offline rl
we have in orange
uh what it was the best trajectory data
set so the offline data is not perfect
um uh so we just plot what is the upper
bound on the offline
data performance
and
here we find that
um for the majority of the environments
there is
a good fit between the target return we
feed in and the actual performance of
the model
and there are some other
observations which
i wanted to take from this slide is that
because we can vary this notion of
reward
uh we can in some sense do multitask rl
by reward condition return conditioning
this is not the only way to do multitask
rl you can specify a task via natural
language you can buy a gold state and so
on forth but this is one notion where
the notion of a task could be how much
reward you want
um
and another thing to notice is
occasionally the smallest extrapolate
this is not a trend we have been seeing
consistently but we do see some signs of
it so if you look at for example sequest
uh here the highest return trajectory in
a data set was pretty low
and if we specify a return higher than
that
for our decision transformer we do find
that the model is able to achieve
so it is able to generate trajectories
uh with returns higher than it ever saw
in the days
um
i i do believe that future work in this
space trying to improve this model
should should think about um
how can this trend be more consistent
across environments because this would
really achieve the goal of alpine rl
which is given sub-optimal behavior
how do you get optimum behavior out of
it
that remains to be seen how well this
trend can be made consistent across
environments
can i jump in with a question
yes
so i i think that last point is really
interesting and it's cool that you guys
occasionally see it um
i'm curious to know what happens so this
is all condition you you give as an
input what return you would like and it
tries to select a sequence of actions
that gives it i'm curious to know what
happens if you just give it ridiculous
inputs like um for example you know here
here the order of magnitude for the
return is like 50 to 100 what happens if
you put in 10 000
uh good question and this is something
we tried early on um
i don't want to say if we went up to 10
000 but we try like really high returns
which not even an expert would get and
generally we see this leveling
performance so you can see hints of it
in half cheetah
and
you know pong as well or
walker to some extent like if you look
at the very end things start saturating
so if you exceed what uh is like
um certain threshold which often
corresponds with the best trajectory
threshold but not always
beyond that everything is similar
returns so
it's not that it so at least one good
thing is it does not degrade in
performance so it would have been a
little bit worrying if you specified a
return of 10 000 and gives you a return
which is
20 or something really low
uh so it is it's good that it stabilizes
but it's not that it keeps increasing on
and on so there there would be a point
where the performance will get saturated
okay thank you
uh i was just curious like so usually
for transfer models you need a lot of
data so do you know how well like uh
like how much data do you need like how
to where does it scale with data the
performance
submission transformer yeah so here we
use uh
uh the standard um
um
data like the d4 rl benchmarks for
which i think have million uh
transitions in the order of millions
for
um
atari we used one percent of the replay
buffer which is smaller than the one we
used for
um
the the major benchmarks and i actually
have a result in the very next slide
which shows
um
decision transformer especially being
useful when you have
a little data
so
uh
yeah so i guess one question to ask
before you move on
um in the last slide uh what do you mean
again by return conditioning for the
multitask part
yeah so if you think about the returns
to go at test time the one you feel have
to feed in as the starting token
um
as one way of
specifying
uh
what policy you want
why
how is that multi-task
so it's multi-task in the sense that
uh because you can get different
policies by changing your target return
to go
you're essentially getting different
behaviors encoded so think about for
instance a hopper and you specify a
return to go that's really low
so you're basically saying
get me an agent which will just stick
around its initial state
and not go into unchartered
unchartered um territory
and if you give it really really high
then you're asking it to do the
traditional
task which is to hop and go as far as
possible without falling
can you qualify those multitasks because
that basically just means that your
return conditioning is a cue for it to
memorize right which is usually like one
of the pitfalls of multi-task
uh so i'm not sure it's a task
identifier that's what i'm trying to say
uh so i'm not sure if it's memorization
uh because
uh
like i think the purpose of this uh
i mean have like having an offline data
set that's fixed is basically saying
that
it's
very very specific to if you had the
same start state
and you took the same actions and you
had the same target returns
that would qualify as memorization
but here at test time we allow all of
these things to change
and in fact they do change so your
initial state would be different
your
target return
uh which could be very could be a
different scalar than one you ever saw
during training
uh it uh
yeah and
uh so essentially the model has to learn
to generate that behavior starting from
a different initial state and maybe a
different value of the target return
than it saw
during
um
during training if the dynamics are
stochastic that also makes so that even
if you memorize the actions you're not
guaranteed to get the next the same next
state
so
you would actually have a bad
correlation with the performance if the
dynamics are also stochastic
uh also was very curious how much time
does it take to train distant
transformer
in general
so it takes about a few hours uh so
um i want to stay like uh
about to five hours
uh depending on what quality gpu you use
but yeah that's that's
a reasonable estimate yep got it thanks
okay so uh actually while doing this
experiment uh this project we thought of
a baseline which we were surprised it's
not there in previous literature on
offline rl but
makes very much sense and uh we thought
we should also think about whether the
decision transformer is actually doing
something very similar to that baseline
and the baseline is what we call as
person behavioral cloning
so behavioral cloning what it does is
basically it ignores the returns
and simply imitates
the
agent
by looking by just trying to map the
actions uh
given the current states
um
this is not a good idea with an offline
data set which will have trajectories of
both low returns and high returns
so traditional behavior cloning it's
common to see that as a baseline in
offline rl methods and
it is unless you have a very high
quality data set
it does this is not a good baseline for
offline rl
however there is a version that we call
as person bc which actually makes quite
a lot of sense and in this version
we filter out the top trajectories from
our offline data set
one stop the ones which have the highest
rewards you know the rewards
for each transition you calculate the
returns of the trajectories and you take
the trajectories with the highest
returns
um and keep a certain percentage of them
which is going to be hyper parameter
here
and once you keep those top fraction of
your trajectories
you then just ask your model
to imitate them
which
so imitation learning also uses
especially when it's used in the form of
behavioral cloning it uses supervised
learning essentially it's a supervised
learning problem so you could actually
also get supervised learning
objective functions if you did this
filtering step
so
and what we find uh actually that for
the moderate and high data regimes the
decent transform is actually very
comparable to push and pc so it's a very
strong baseline which i think all of
future work in offline rls should
include
there's actually an iclear submission
from last week which
has a much more detailed analysis on
just this baseline that we introduced in
this paper
and
uh what we do find is that for low data
regimes the decision transformer does
much better than person behavior cloning
so this is for the atari benchmarks
where
like i previously mentioned we have a
much smaller data set
as compared to the mojoku
uh environments and here we find that
for
even after varying the different
fraction of the percentage hyper
parameter here
we are generally not able to get the
strong performance that a resident
transformer gets
um
so 10 bc basically means that we filter
out and keep the top 10 percent of the
trajectories
if you go
even lower then the star data set
becomes very small so the baseline will
become meaningless
uh but for even the reasonable ranges we
never find the performance matching that
of different transformers
for these atari benchmarks
uh
uh if i may
um so i notice in table three for
example which is not this table with one
just before in the paper
there's a report on the cql performance
which to me also feels you know
intuitively pretty similar to the
percent bc in the sense of like you pick
trajectories you know performing well
and you try and stay roughly within sort
of the same kind of uh policy
distribution um
and state space distribution
uh
i was i was curious on this one do you
have a sense of what the cql performance
was relative to say
um the percent bc performance here
uh so that's a great question so the
question is that
uh
even for cql you rely on this notion of
pessimism
where
you want to pick trajectories where
you're more confident in and try to make
sure policy remains in that region
uh so i don't have the numbers of secret
on
this table but if you look at the
detailed results for atari
uh
then i think uh
they should they should have the secret
for sure uh because that's the numbers
we are reporting
here
so i can tell you what the secret
performance is actually pretty good and
it's very competitive
with the decision transformer for atari
so this uh td learning
baseline here is secret
uh so
naturally by extension i would imagine
it doing better than person bc
yeah and i apologize if this was
mentioned i just missed it but
do you have the sense that this is
basically like a failure of cql to be
able to extrapolate well or sort of
um stitch together different parts of
trajectories
uh whereas the decision transformer can
sort of make that extrapolation between
you have like the first half of one
projector is really good the second half
which one trajectory is really good so
you can actually piece those together
decision transformer where you can't
necessarily do that with cql because the
path connecting those may not
necessarily be well covered by the
behavior policy
yeah yeah so uh and this uh this
actually goes uh to one of the
intuitions which um
i i did not emphasize too much but we
have a discussion on the paper where
essentially why do we expect a
transformer or any wall for that matter
to look at offline data that's
sub-optimal and get something a policy
which generates optimal rollouts
the intuition is that
as
scott was mentioning you could perhaps
stitch together
uh good behaviors from sub-optimal
trajectories and that stitching could
perhaps lead to a behavior that was
better than anything you saw in
individual trajectories in your data set
uh it's
something we find early evidence of in a
you know
small scale experiment for
graphs
and that's really our hope also that
something that the transformer is very
good at
uh because it can attend to very long
sequences so it could identify those
segments of behavior
which
uh when stitched together would give you
optimal
uh
optimal behavior
so um
and and and it's very much possible that
is something unique to this in
transformers and something like cql
would not be able to do person bc
because it's filtering out the data
is automatically being limited and not
being able to do that because the
segments of good behavior could be in
trajectories which overall do not have a
high return but so if you filter them
out
you are losing all of that information
okay so i said there is a hyper
parameter the context and k and uh like
with
most of perception one of the big
advantages of transformers as opposed to
other sequence models like lstms is that
they can process very
large sequences
um and here
uh at a first glance it might seem that
being markovian would have been helpful
for rl
uh which also was a question that was
raised earlier uh so we did this
experiment where we did compare
performance with context and k equals
one
and here
we had
context spent between
uh 30 for the environments and 54 pound
and we find that increasing the context
length is is very very important to get
good performance
okay
now
so
so
so far i've i've showed you um how
this in transformer which is very simple
uh
there was no slide i had which was going
into the details of dynamic programming
which just which is the crux of most rl
uh this is just pure supervised learning
in an auto regressive framework that was
getting us as good performance
um
what about uh cases where this approach
actually starts outperforming
some of the traditional methods or
so to probe a little bit further we
started looking at sparse reward
environments and
uh basically we just took our existing
mojoque environments and then
instead of giving it the information for
reward for every transition
we fed it the cumulative reward at the
end of the trajectory so every
transition will have a zero reward
except the very end where you get the
entire reward at once so it's a very
sparse reward perform
[Music]
scenario for that reason
and here we find that
compared to the original dense
results the delayed uh results for dt
they will deteriorate a little bit which
is expected because now you are
withholding some of the more
fine-grained information at every time
step but the drop is
uh
not too significant compared to the
original dt performance here
whereas for something like cql there is
a drastic drop in performance
so cql suffers quite a lot in sparse
rewards there are new scenarios
uh but the decision transformer does not
and uh just for completeness you also
have performance of behavioral cloning
and personal behavior cloning which
because they don't look at reward
information
except maybe person bc looks at only for
pre-processing the data set
these are agnostic to whether the
environments are have sponsor words or
not
would you expect this to be different if
you were doing online rl
um
what's the intuition for it being
different aprilia i would say no but
it's maybe i'm missing out on a key
piece of intuition behind that question
um
i think that because you're training
like offline right like your the next
input will always be the correct action
in that sense so you don't just like
deviate and like go off the rails
technically because you just don't know
so i could see like how online would
have like a really hard
like cold start basically because it
just doesn't know and it's just
happening in the dark until it like
maybe eventually hits the jackpot
right right i i think i agree that's so
that's a good piece of uh
uh intuition out there that yeah i think
here
because offline rl is really
getting rid of the trial and error
aspect of it and first pass
reward environments that would be
harder so
the drop in
dt performance should
uh be more prominent there
um i'm not sure how it would compare
with
the drop performance for other
algorithms so
uh but it will it it does seem like an
interesting
um setup to test uh dtm
well
and i did to maybe i'm wrong here but my
understanding with the decision
transformer as well is this is this
critical piece that in the training you
use the rewards to go right so is it is
it not the sense that essentially like
for each trajectory from the initial
state based on the training regime
the model has access to whether or not
the final result was
a uh success or failure right
but that's sort of that's sort of a
unique aspect of the training regime for
decision transformers whereas in cql
uh
my understanding is that it's based on
sort of a per transition
training regime and so each transition
is decoupled somewhat to what the final
reward was is that correct
uh yes um although like one difficulty
which at a first glance you kind of
imagined the different transformer
having is that
that initial token will not change
throughout the trajectory
yeah
because it's just past reward scenarios
so except the very last token where it
will drop down to zero all of a sudden
this token remains the same throughout
uh but maybe that that
but i think you're right that maybe just
even at the start
um
feeding it in a manner which looks at
the future rewards that you need to get
to is is perhaps
one part of the reason why the drop in
performance is
uh not noticeable
yeah i mean i guess one sort of ablation
experiment here would be if you if you
change the training regime
so that only the last trajectory had the
um had the reward but i don't i'm trying
to think about whether or not that would
just be uh compensated for by sort of
the attention mechanism anyway
um
and vice versa right if you if you
embedded that reward information into
the cql training procedure as well i'd
be curious to see what would happen
there
yeah
good experience
okay so related to this um there's
another environment we tested uh i gave
you a brief preview of the results in
one of the earlier slides so this is
called the keycard environment
and it has three phases so in the first
phase you've
the agent is placed in a room with the
key
um
a good agent will pick up the key and
then phase two it will be placed in an
empty room
and in phase three
it will be placed in a room with a door
which will act where it will actually
use
the key that it collected in phase one
if it did to open the door
uh so
essentially the agent is going to
receive a binary reward
corresponding to whether it
reached and
opened the door in phase three
conditioned on the fact that it
uh
did pick up the key in phase one
so there is this
national notion of that you want to
assign credit to something that happened
to an even that happened really really
in the past so it's a very challenging
uh and uh
sensible scenario if you wanted to rest
in models for how well they are at
long-term credit assignment
and
here we find that
uh so we tested it for different amounts
of trajectories so here the number of
trajectories basically says how often
would you actually see this kind
of behavior
and the instant transformer
is and person behavioral cloning both of
these actually baselines
uh do
do much better than other models which
struggle at this
task
um
there's there's a related experiment
there which is um
also of interest so generally a lot of
algorithms have this notion of an actor
and a critic
actor is basically someone
that takes actions conditioned on the
states so think of a policy
a critic is
basically evaluating
how good these actions are in terms of
achieving a long-term
um
in terms of this accumulative sum of
rewards in the long term
uh this is a good environment because uh
we can see how
uh
how well the distant transformer would
do if it was trained as a critic so here
what we did is
instead of having the actions as the
output target
what if we substituted that with the
rewards
so
that's very much possible
we can again use the same causal
transformer machinery
uh to only look at
transitions in the previous time step
and try to pick the reward
and here we see this interesting pattern
where
in the three phases that we had in that
key to do our environment
we do see the reward probability
changing very much in in
how we expect so basically
the three scenarios so the agent the
first scenario let's look at bloom
in which the agent does not pick up the
key
in phase one
so the reward probability they all start
around the same
but as it becomes apparent that the
agent is not going to pick up the key
the reward starts going down
and then it stays very much
close to zero throughout
the episode because there is no way you
will have the key to open the door in
the future phases
if you pick up the key
there are two possibilities
uh
which
remain which are which are essentially
the same in phase two where you are in
an empty room
uh which is just a distractor to make
the episode really long
but at the very end the two
possibilities are one that you take the
key and you actually reach the door
which is the one we see in
orange and brown here where you see that
the reward probability goes up
and this is this other possibility that
you actually pick up the key but do not
reach the door in which case again it
starts seeing that
the reward probability that's predicted
starts going down
so
uh the takeaway from this experiment is
that listen transformers are not just
great actors which is what we've been
seeing so far the results
uh the
for from the optimized policy but
they're also very impressive critics in
doing this long-term period and
assignment uh where the reward is also
very sparse
uh so just to be correct are you
predicting the rewards to go at each
time step or is it is this like the
type like the rewarded
so this was the rewards to go uh
and um
i can also check my my impression was in
this particular experiment it didn't
really make a difference whether you
were predicting rewards to go or the
actual rewards
uh but i think we're gonna chance to
move for this one also most curious so
how do you get the probability
distribution of the rewards is it just
like you just evaluate a lot of
different episodes and just for the
rewards or are you explicitly predicting
some sort of distribution
oh so so this is a binary reward so you
can have uh so you can have a
probabilistic outcome
got it
when you have a question uh yeah so
generally we will call like some
something predicts the state value or
state action value as critic but in this
case you you ask this transformer to
only predict uh rewards so why do you
still call it a critic
so i i think the analogy here gets a bit
clearer with returns to go like if you
think what it turns to go it's really
capturing that essence that you want to
see the future rewards that oh i say so
assuming this is gonna predict the
return to goal instead of single step
reward right
yeah yeah
okay so so if you're gonna predict uh
written struggle is kind of
counterintuitive to me because in
phase one when the agent is still in the
key room i think you should have a like
high retest goal if it did after k
but
in but in the plot
you know in the k room
the agents pick up k and the agent that
didn't pick up k has the same
kind of level of returns to go so that's
quite
intuitive to me
i think this is this is reflecting on
uh
a good property which is that your
distribution
like if you if you interpret returns to
go in the right way in phase one you
don't know which of these three outcomes
are really possible and phase one also
i'm talking about the very beginning
basically uh slowly you will learn about
it but
essentially
in
in phase one if you see the returns to
go as
uh one or zero uh for for uh it it all
three possibilities are equally likely
and all three possibilities
uh so if we try to evaluate the
predicted
reward for these possibilities it should
be the same
because we really haven't done
we don't know what's going to happen in
in in phase three
sorry it's my mistake because i cuz
previously that salter green lime is the
agent which doesn't pick up decay but
it turns out the blue line is asian
which doesn't pick up
okay so yeah it's my mistake okay it
makes sense to me thank you
uh also was not uh
like fully clear from the paper but did
you do experiments where you're like
predicting both the actions and both the
rewards to go and like does it like
can it improve performance if you're
doing both together so um
actually we did some preliminary
experiments on that and it didn't help
us much however i do want to again put
in a plug for a paper that came
concurrently trajectory transformer
which
uh tried to predict um
states actions and rewards actually all
three of them
uh they were in a model-based setup
where it made sense also to
uh try to learn each of the components
like the transition dynamics the policy
and maybe even the critic in their setup
together
we did not find any significant
improvements so in favor of simplicity
and keeping it model free we did not
try to predict them together
got it
okay so the summary um
we showed this in transformers which is
a first work in trying to approach rl
based on sequence modeling
the main advantages over previous
approaches is it's simple by design the
hope is
with further extensions we will find it
to scale much better than existing our
algorithms
it is stable to train because the loss
functions we are using
have been tested and
i traded upon a lot by
research and perception
and in the future we will also hope that
because of these similarities with
uh in the architecture and the training
with
how perception based tasks are conducted
it would also be easy to integrate them
within this loop so the states
um the actions or even the tasks of
interest they could be specified
based on
uh
perceptual base sensors so you could
have
a target
tasks being specified by natural
language instruction
and because these models can very well
play with these kinds of inputs the hope
is that they would be easy to integrate
within the decision making
process
and empirically we saw strong
performance in the range of offline rl
settings
and especially good performance
in scenarios which required us to do
long term credit assignment
uh so there's a lot of future work this
is definitely
uh
not
the end this is a first work in
rethinking how do we build
rl agents that can scale and generalize
um
a few things that i picked out which i
feel would be very exciting
uh to extend
uh the first is multi-modality
so really one of our big motivations
with going after
these kinds of models is that we can
combine different kinds of inputs both
online and offline
uh to really build decision making
agents which work like humans
uh we process so many inputs around us
in different modalities and we
act on them so we do take decisions
and we want the same to happen in
artificial agents and maybe decision
transformers is one
important step in that
route
uh multitask so
i showed uh or i described very limited
form of multitasking here which was
based on
the desired returns to go
uh but it could be more richer in terms
of
specifying
a command to be a robot or a desired
goal state which could be for example
even visual
uh so trying to better explore the
different multi-task capabilities of
this model but also
be an interesting extension
uh finally uh multi-agent
uh
as human beings we never act in
isolation we are always acting
within
um an environment that involves many
many more agents um things become
partially observable in those scenarios
which place to the strengths of distant
transformers being non-markovian by
design
so
i think there is great possibilities of
exploring even multi-agent scenarios
where the fact that transformers can
process fairly large sequences compared
to existing algorithms could again help
build better models of other agents
in your environment and act
so that yeah there's some just useful
links in case you're interested uh the
project website the paper and the code
are all
public
and i'm happy to take any more questions
uh sure okay so i said thanks for the
good talk uh really appreciated everyone
had a good time here
um
so i think we are like near the class
limit um
so usually i have like a round of
reference five questions for the speaker
that's just like the students usually
know uh but like if someone is a hurry
you can you just like
uh ask general questions first
um before we stop the recording so if
anyone wants to like uh leave earlier at
this time uh just feel free to ask your
questions
um
otherwise i will just like continue on
uh so what do you think is like the
future of like transformers in other do
you think they will take over like uh
they've already taken over like language
and vision so do you think for like
model based and like moderate learning
do you think you'll see a lot more like
transformers pop up in our literature
uh yes uh i i think we'll see a flurry
of work um if not already we have good
there's so many works using transformers
at this year's eye clear conference
um
having said that i feel that an
important piece of the puzzle that needs
to be solved is expiration
it's
non-trivial
and it will
have to my my guess is that you will
have to forgo some of the
advantages that i talked about for
transformers in terms of loss functions
to actually enable expiration
uh so
i
it remains to be seen whether those
modified loss functions
for expiration
actually
uh hurt performance significantly
uh but as long as we cannot cross that
uh bottleneck i think uh it it it is
i'm not i i do not want to commit that
this is indeed the
future of rl
got it
uh also like you think like something
sure um i'm not sure understood that
point so you're saying that in order to
apply transformers in rl do exploration
there have to be particular loss
functions and and they're tricky for
some reason
yeah could you explain more like what
are what are the modified loss functions
and why do they seem tricky
so
essentially in expiration
you have to do the opposite of
exploitation which is non-aggregate
[Music]
and there is right now no
nothing inbuilt in the transformer right
now which encourages that sort of random
behavior
uh where you seek out
uh
unfamiliar uh unfamiliar parts of the
state space
that is something which is inbuilt into
traditional rl algorithms
so you usually have some sort of entropy
bonus to encourage expiration
and those are the sort of modifications
which
one will also need to think about
if one were to use this and transformers
for
online rl
so what happens if somebody i mean just
naively suppose i have this exact same
setup and the way that i sample the
action is i i sample epsilon greedily or
i create a boltzmann distribution and i
sample from that i mean just what
happens it seems
that's what rl does so does what happens
so rl does a little bit more than that
it indeed does those kinds of
things where it would change the
distribution for example to be a
personal distribution and sample from it
but it's also there there are these uh
as i said the devil lies in the detail
it's also about how it controls that
exploration component with the
exploitation
and it's an um it it remains to be seen
whether that is compatible or decision
transformers
i don't want to jump the gun but i would
say it's it's i mean um
preliminary evidence suggests that it's
not directly transferable the exact same
uh setup to
the online case that's what we have
found
there has to be some adjustments to be
made to make yeah which we we are still
figuring it out
so the the reason why i ask is as you
said the devil's in the details and so
someone naively like me might just come
along and try doing what's in rl i want
to hear more about this so you're saying
that what works in rl may not work for
decision transformers
can you tell us
why like what pathologies emerge um
what what are those devils uh hiding in
the details
uh also remind you like sorry we are
like all over time so if you know
and i'm sure that it's tricky
um yeah i'll just ask like two more
questions um and like
after those so one is uh like other did
you think uh like something like this in
transformer is a way to solve the data
center problem in oil instead of using
some sort of like this one factor
uh
sorry that can you repeat the question
oh sorry yes i think usually in rl we
have to rely on some sort of
disconfected to encode the rewards to go
something like that but it's in
transformer transformers able to do this
credit assignment
uh without that so do you think like uh
some something like this book is like
the way you should do it like we should
like instead of having some discount try
to directly predict
rewards
so i i would go on to say that i feel
that discount factor is an important
consideration in general and
it's not incompatible with discipline
transformers so basically what would
change
and i think the code actually gives that
functionality where
the returns to go would be computed as
the discounted sum of rewards
so it is very much compatible so there
are scenarios where
uh our context length is still is not
enough to actually capture the long-term
behavior
we really need for credit assignment
maybe traditional tricks
um that are used could be brought in
back to solve those kinds of problems
got it yeah i also thought like when i
was reading the
decision transfer work that the
interesting thing is
that you don't have a fixed drama like a
gamma is like usually a hyper parameter
but like
you don't have a fixed gamma so do you
think like can you also like learn this
thing and could this also be like can
you have a different karma for each
chamstick or something possibly
uh that would be interesting actually i
i had not thought of that but
um maybe
learning to predict this non-factor
could be another extension of this work
also do you think like this like uh this
transformer work is like like is it
compatible with q learning so if you're
something like cql stuff like that can
you also implement those sort of loss
functions on top of like decision
transformer
uh so um i think um maybe
could imagine ways in which you could
encode pessimism in here
uh as well which which is which is key
to
our secret words
uh and actually most of um
of the nrl algorithms work uh including
the model based ones
right uh our focus here deliberately was
to go after simplicity
uh because we feel that part of the
reason why our literature has been so
scattered as well if you think about
different sub problems everyone tries to
solve has been because
everyone's
tried to
pick up on ideas which
are very well suited for that narrow
uh
narrow problem like for example you have
and whether you're doing offline or
reading online or you're doing imitation
you're doing multitask and all these
different variants
and
uh so by design we did not we we were
very step we did not want to incorporate
exactly the components that exist in a
um in the current algorithms uh because
then it just when it starts looking more
like a
architecture change as opposed to a more
conceptual change into thinking about
rls sequence modeling
uh very generally
yeah that sounds interesting
so do you think we can use some sort of
like like tv learning objectives instead
of supervised learning um
[Music]
it's possible uh and
maybe like i'm saying that for certain
like for online rl it might be necessary
yeah often rl we were happy to see it
was uh not necessary
but that it remains to be seen more
generally for a transformer model or any
other model for that matter encompassing
rl more broadly whether that
uh becomes a necessity
all right yeah
well thanks for your time this was great